this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
let's get going here buddy how you
feeling buddy how was your we took an
early flight tomorrow tough because I
got to bed around two after I couldn't
fall asleep I couldn't either so it was
after Mr Rogan now I think it was the
I'm not a big cigar guy but when in Rome
did you smoke a cigar I didn't see two
of them really well you don't pay
attention I didn't I didn't see the
entire show out of cigarette really I
didn't see that once that's so weird to
me didn't do the show without a cigar
are you kidding yeah wow I only saw Joe
smoking a cigar but I like cigar smoke I
like the way it smells but that'll
you're sitting right across me you don't
pay attention huh that's so weird the
entire show I never saw you once oh
Non-Stop and I've heard Joe's I I
haven't done a price since high school
and I was like yeah they might be cool
usually me and Joe like the same things
and he's like you want cigars like yeah
sure and I was like this thing's great I
loved it oh yeah I loved it tasty and he
saw me running low he's like you want
another I'm like fired up I went through
a little period when I would smoke
cigars wouldn't drink some red wine I
love the kitchen nice and high promise
I'm a little I get a little nauseous
after a while it's not for you the
certain stuff like if I've eaten
electrons guns guys
no I like trucks I like whiskey no I
like whiskey don't say that although I
was drinking sake yeah yeah it's just a
little softer dude no I'm just
my my palette is super refined and I
will say this guys you're probably
noticing something about how Marshall my
head looks and how well it sort of
Blends in with my rather thick and
athletic neck I'm not gonna lie to you
you're here's the worst ever no no no no
no no no no
no I'm trying to be crazy
if you look here about
it it's so bad Bob look you have
camouflage in here where's my where's my
camera it's so bad guys you're listen
we're in a fire no listen I got no you
know your hair looks like you ever seen
home alone when Vinnie no no no no I
don't like this
no no I got I got Sean Strickland hair
and I did it in homage to Sean and we
have very it's funny very funny because
I thought to myself I could never use
Philly shell but now see the one where
he's cooling off right there there's
Brian's
great reference it's amazing how you
remember these things that's from that's
super insulting accurate but insulting
now here's the thing did you cut it last
night I did I shaved my own head now the
problem is I screwed up the back because
I took a I couldn't see what I was doing
so that I had to go on a tree I was
really bad there are some issues you
gotta do the whole thing there are some
issues I don't want to talk about it we
had a good time in Austin I went to
Comedy Mothership how good the Green
Room when all the boys talking smack
yeah Andrew Schultz was there Schultz
he's there and all of them
son yeah you you tripping given out old
school stories you forget how nourishing
to the soul that hang is that's kind of
almost you can't separate the Hang
before you do stand up and after you
just stand up with stand-up like when
you're at a club like that yes well you
have a place to go every night or at
least three nights a week it was our
chairs that was that yeah that was that
was The Comedy Store yeah and that's
gone that sucked and I wrote well Rogan
was like I'm just gonna do it here
and did he ever it was cool
I felt a little bad about myself all
weekend why because you're around a
billionaire
uh it's not that I'm used to being
around people who have more money I just
feel like
I feel like I
I don't know I just wish I could start a
comedy club somewhere but then I don't
know that's not for you it's not fun I
don't know why you do this to yourself I
know that's like hanging out I just do
stuff like hang out with Elon Musk like
God I want to get to Mars I know you're
right you in a comedy
clubs huh we got money stolen from us
and you had no clue till I told you
there if you want to run a comedy store
you're right by the way let's take a
minute to explain you want to address
that I think we should explain what uh
the the get off of that Segway come on
dude I've been doing this a long time
that was good
professional black belt I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna tell everybody what well
before you do the so
we spoke with coffee Zilla Stephen who
I'm a big fan of and obviously Theo Von
uh uh announced on his YouTube channel
what exactly some of the issues we've
been having as far as what the podcast
game goes yeah with what he's having but
he also alluded when he when he kept
saying we it's it's me and Theo right
because when we had King The Sting so
Theo said his piece and then
um yeah then copy Zilla reached out and
yes because I'm behind the scenes again
if you guys watch the show long enough I
don't like the drama stuff I don't like
you know I also don't think you guys are
very interested in behind the scenes the
numbers and so I was like well I I don't
think and then once Theo was like we
gotta I'm gonna do something here I was
like do your thing player and then you
know he went off and did his thing
that's like door's open I think what's
important is to stick to just the facts
and with what happened to us I don't
think it was very relevant to our
listenership since the comedy podcast to
get into what like the number amount of
money we were that we are missing I
don't think they care that was taken
from us so uh over we we had been doing
uh our our advertising agent was cast
media we've had several before that but
but in the past 10 years or so three to
four years four years a little over four
uh Colin Thompson who owns cast uh was
making us money not only so remember so
Brandon explained his side of the story
which which it relates to me and him
then remember I have you know the shop
show at the time King the sting which is
now the golden hour combat's fight
campaign food truck so it's a big array
so as the story goes on and you guys are
familiar with I'm sure other podcasts
said they've you know they they didn't
receive money and obviously Theo didn't
receive money no one got more screwed
over than I did not even because because
it crosses a lot of other shows not just
one yeah and we'll tell you the numbers
so so what I find out from my accountant
your accountant we share the same
accountants was
um that fighter and the kid was owed
somewhere around 476
000 dollars
then I find out that thick Boy
Productions overall is owed and this is
the number I was that was floated from
our accounts before they'd done a real
investigation around 1.5 1.6 million
dollars I don't know if you guys if that
doesn't seem like a lot of money to you
guys that's a lot of money and that's
not something I can just go whatever
so something's up what is up I'm not
going to speculate on but we knew that
we were owed this money and the way I
know the way it would work was typically
every three months we'd get a large
chunk of money and that's kind of how
podcasting Works my guess is net 90 days
yeah so you do a bunch of reads and then
you get a check after nine 90 days but
and that was always the way it was until
probably months went by when we were
getting what would what we call our
minimum guarantee to keep the lights on
pair employees
eight months without those big lump sums
yeah I didn't know I didn't know that
exactly but it was a long time so I have
a new account and after a while the
accounts go hold on world this is really
accruing this is like a tab that's like
I got you you owe some money after eight
months what's going on
so at the end of the day I called Colin
and I'm just going to tell you what the
conversation was with Colin essentially
I started talking to him and I stopped
him and I said Colin it sounds like you
got in over your skis
there was a lull in advertising revenue
and you started using our money at this
point I thought it was just us that was
for me uh you started using our money to
pay your payroll and he said that's
basically what happened
so I said and then there was talk of him
selling his company to podcast one and I
said where is that deal and I heard a
couple of things and I hung up the phone
I called you and I said we're not going
to see our money and that sale is not
going to go through it doesn't make any
sense but I just stopped listening but I
listened to Jocko and I went well good
yeah the dog then we got a dog with a
1.6 million good and then we got
he took extreme 1.6
good yes so dog with a bone said oh hell
no and what I did at that point is I
went on vacation you did I had to go
away for 10 days where did I go I can't
remember to Greece I went to wherever it
was I know I didn't get to go on
vacation because I was dealing with this
yeah I said I'm gonna take my wife my
kid and I'm gonna go away and then
you're checking I mean hey did you get
our money it's going hey Brian I'm in
the trenches you enjoy this
of the day what you guys have to realize
is that that Brennan spoke to and I'll
let you speak on this more Brennan spoke
to a number of agencies and the company
that gave us the best deal when we were
out this money was a company called
podcast one podcast one has been the
Agents of a lot of the people that we
know and they've been very happy with
them Adam Carolla Dr Drew Etc they've
been in business a long time from what I
can tell have a very good reputation uh
they gave us yeah they gave us the best
deal and we went with that because I was
not in a position neither was Brennan to
say oh well we'll just write that off oh
no we were now in terms of what what
podcast one's deal was with Colin
we don't know they weren't going to
disclose that but what we did have in
the contract was that Colin could have
nothing to do with fighter in the kit or
any of my shoes and that's in the
contract yeah I met with everybody from
there then from there from my
perspective I'm speaking for me I
started to see that this cast debacle
was more systemic and that we weren't
the only podcast who had taken these
losses and so now that is an ongoing
thing that I will allow people like
coffeezilla to unfold to look at who we
spoke to we spoke to copy zilan they can
speculate on that all they want but let
me tell you what happens in situations
like that like this if something like
this happens you better be very careful
about how you speak about it on public
platforms very careful and you better
stick to just the facts and I've learned
the hard way over the past 12 years to
say only what I know for sure I don't
know and to keep my mouth shut about
everything else but going forward
um I think right now we're in a good
place yeah one of the reasons I don't
talk about it's also talk about it
doesn't do too much it might help out
the maybe people that can't talk about
it I guess that was Theo's things behind
it that's not but but to me it's it I go
good to quote Jocko good now you get to
work it's your my issues aren't your
guys's issues I got to figure out to
keep these lights on otherwise there's
no show yes also and so you call me a
bulldog we'd also don't know what other
people's issues are no I don't know the
nitty-gritty I know I don't know
anything about that I don't even know
how much Theo was owed
um I I didn't know well Theo hadn't been
with the company I guess for about no he
left another one so so all I know is he
called it from from day one he just he
wasn't a fan of cast from day one
okay you get that right yeah I don't
know but yeah so we got to work that's
the uh we landed on our feet thanks God
that's what happened as far as we are
concerned and I am sure more details
will emerge coffee Zillow releases uh
who knows but we smoked coffee Zilla and
then if he's on a Case he'll he'll he's
yeah he's a good Stephen's a great dude
and then yeah we I met with it you know
we've been in the business so long I met
with I flew to Texas I flew everywhere
to meet with all these podcast uh
advertisers speak to them on the phone
me and my manager Lex again you think
I'm a bulldog
didn't you yeah I did didn't you have a
fainting spell or anything I have a
bigger bulldog in Lex McMahon behind me
so you gotta deal with me and Lex good
luck Lex McMahon is um was a marine he's
a Marine and is uh in my opinion one of
the uh best people
on the planet like a man who you can
depend on who sticks it out and they
don't make them like and he got his
vision fix now and he can my favorite
thing about Lex McMahon my favorite
thing about you couldn't see for years
yes but there's no better man and uh man
who you can rely on and all you got to
know about Lex is when the hurricane
there was a category 5 hurricane coming
right at his house and they said to
everybody you got to get out of here
you're gonna die and Lex said not
leaving stocked up on beef jerky I'm I'm
gonna Stare this I'm I'm not going away
this is where I live and I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna board up the hatches he
was going to be like like uh like when
when the if Lex was on the Titanic he
would have been plugging holes this is
this is how Artie Lange described uh
Michael Jordan and I'm going to describe
Lex McMahon that way and Lex was like
not going anywhere I'm gonna face the
eye of the hurricane thank God it just
missed him it decided that hurricane
last minute was like we're gonna go over
here but I went oh that's a different
dude that's a guy I could never be and
I'm glad he's in my corner that's all I
have to say because the zombie
apocalypse hits first guy we're calling
is Lexington he was my first call yeah I
did have a panic attack that was a heart
attack passed out and woke up all good
baby I went good
but I got I got legs behind me at Jan I
get a great team Jan's another one I
think I don't know Jan well no but Jan
Jan is older than everyone
is smarter than all dressed dressed like
a gentleman at all times and mind your
piece and cues are out man because he
comes in and he's a fixer too he's the
he's you know what he is he's an old
school cleaner you got a problem I got a
squad you gotta call Jan but guess what
you won't see him he'll just be in and
out and you'll be like what the [__]
happened yeah I got a squad now I got to
tighten up the team uh honestly I know I
make for it good but that's why I was
like all right I gotta figure out good
I'm gonna tighten up the team get rid of
the loose people or a little
loosey-goose with my money can't count
yeah I have to own the fact that I am
probably along with you but I'm I think
I take the crown I think it's a it's I
win by a nose hair
I don't manage anything and I'm Jeff
Bezos you could take everything you want
you're the worst ever you could steal
everything from me and I'd be like what
I'd be like Brian you got a dollar this
month like yeah that's all right I have
a mental block when it comes to money
promotion and everything and I I I
haven't gotten over it and I'm
embarrassed but um I don't when it comes
to that but it sucks but I'm just glad
it's all over I'm [__] good luck dude
I have to go to a therapist nah you'll
be all right man but yeah shout out to
Coffee Zilla shout out to podcast again
I met with everybody in the biz I've
been in business long time so I know
everybody for the the most part I
reached out to everyone when I was like
we're a free agent for the first time
how many years and Rob uh Kitt and Sue
at podcast one I was like this by far
the best team we've met with by far the
best deal I don't care about any of the
other stuff going on let's move forward
that's why I don't even talk about it
it's like nobody cares about your
problems man yeah you just move forward
otherwise everybody in here including
you we don't have a job dude so I have
to get to work man and this is and the
time I tell you I cut your salary by 75
and so the hustle and and so the hustle
begins yeah hustle begins my man are you
stressed out I take nicotine I did pass
out during that crazy time
what's that called uh Buffalo uh black
Buffalo dude yep black Buffalo is it
hold on is it made in the U.S you know I
mean come on Daddy you think I drive a
TRX and put china product in my America
that's America
is there any tobacco or stems in there
because I can't I can't deal with it
back on stems tobacco-free Daddy they
got nicotine free and nicotine yeah bud
and if you you know great ingredients oh
it's the best food grade ingredients
edible green leaves dude so this this
one's the straight pouches so I I've
done tobacco products before and this
has the flavors that you like but I like
Peach if they don't have Peach yeah but
I also like blood orange if they don't
have blood orange then you don't talk to
you talk about my dude we talk about
this because those are my favorite what
sometimes I just want straight sometimes
I don't want flavor do they have any
flavor do they have straight flips yeah
dude they do yeah yeah
I always go with the I always go with a
company where I can actually sometimes
when I'm feeling feisty and spicy I like
my I like my winter green and my mint
and that's okay we got that too dude
yeah Daddy black Buffalo man what dude
you think I drive a Dodge TRX and put
some foreign stuff in my mouth oh you
wouldn't put something foreign in your
mouth yeah I mean unless it's Vegas and
you're super hot no even though I look
for American why American America gotta
be American man American man damn man
you said man no maid maid no made made
American map that's my thing yeah
pharmaceutical grade nicotine though
it's where I actually draw the line is
that
B let's take a little break because
football's back and my CU Buffs ranked
number 18 we're gonna beat the brakes
off CSU this Saturday and that's off to
at Oregon and win that Oregon game that
UFC game gets pretty fun pretty fun and
then NFL's here the if you're a Bengals
fan I feel bad for you they looked
atrocious but it could be a lot worse
could be a Giants fan they lost 40-0
against the Dallas Cowboys really and
then if you're a charge fan even worse
they had a chance to beat Miami and then
uh unless play on fourth down they got
sacked so Broncos fan it's not fun
either but I'll tell you what is Fun
making banquet DraftKings while watching
your team lose like I do football is
back at full swing with another week of
epic games you got Aaron Rodgers versus
the bills on Monday Night Football you
have big matchups on week two draftking
Sportsbook and official sports betting
partner of the NFL new customers commit
five dollars on football and get two
hundred dollars instilling bonus bets
nobody's missing out on the action this
season all DraftKings these customers
can take advantage of two new offers
every game day this September get in on
the NFL week two action with DraftKings
Sportsbook download the app right now
use code fighter to sign up new
customers can bet just five dollars and
take home 200 instantly in bonus bets
only in draftking Sportsbook with the
code Fighter the crown is yours go Buffs
gambling problem called 100 gambling or
if it's
www.1800camular.net in New York called
8778 hope and wire text Hope NY 467 369
in Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call
888-789-777 or visit
ccpg.org please play responsibly on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino and Resort KS
21 plus age varies by jurisdiction avoid
in Ontario c c
dkng.com dot Co slash football for
eligibility terms and responsible gaming
resources bonus bets expire seven days
after issuance eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply DraftKings bro code
fighter go Buffs sometimes you get
injured and you it's scary and the only
recourse is a lawsuit remember this when
you sue a lot of times you're suing the
insurance company and that is the
reality sometimes if you're out a lot of
money or you can't work for a long time
you get in a car accident or something
but the problem is a lot of people say
how in the world am I going to suit I
mean I got to get a lawyer well that's
good what do I do what if I told you
there's Morgan and Morgan all right
Morgan Morgan is America's largest
injury Law Firm the over 100 offices
Nationwide and more than 800 lawyers
they've won over 15 billion dollars
recovered for over 300 000 clients
Morgan Morgan has the proven track
record for fighting get your full and
fair it's also super easy I've been
helping people for 35 years submitting
into your claims yeah your phone is
incredibly easy it's like eight clicks
on your phone from your couch so if
you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan Morgan their fee is free it's
free unless they win for more
information go to forthepeople.com
fighter or dial pound law pound 529 from
your cell phone that's for the
people.com fighter or pound law pound
529 from your cell this is a paid
advertisement
um all right
um now now that we're two days removed
from the I think the biggest upset in
UFC history best performance in a
championship fight I've ever seen yeah
thoughts on Strickland don't regret say
whatever they say some original thoughts
thoughts on Strickland is performance
well it's uh can I just speak
technically oh no no not technically I
never saw I thought I'd see a Philly
shell uh utilize successful yeah like I
never thought I'd see a Philly shell and
basically boxing win against mean
potatoes uh yeah a high level Striker
like adesanya and and uh and I didn't
think that seeing somebody who
essentially basically plods forward
plots forward it has one quad bro and
has no one's missing a quad yes
and I think the story there is a couple
things one is one is seeing a guy who
has been quietly sparring if you look at
his body is what I love about strickling
look at his body he's a guy who clearly
isn't doing the state-of-the-art Drago
like uh you know Fitness stuff
there's a million look at Fedor his body
his body comes from
f i g h t i n g he spars and I think
when you Spar that much you don't get
hit as much you have that radar uh hold
on you don't want to Advocate is yeah do
what Strickland does just Spar every day
that's a terrible idea right you got to
realize what works for Strickland works
works for strictly yeah but but so so my
thoughts are are number one I can't
believe I just saw somebody use the
Philly shell he looked like if you ever
watch if you guys want to see what
somebody does Bernard Hopkins is a very
similar stylist Bernard Hopkins actually
so I saw that but more importantly what
I [__] loved was him talking about
his childhood
and saying let's hear it for childhood
trauma and he took the most negative
thing in the world that's him joking
dude I know he is no I'm saying but he
took the most worship with the clip I
sent you he was obviously abused
everything he said he's like yeah give
him for a challenge
goes back I know but he's he took the
worst thing somebody could go through
childhood trauma like that abuse and
he's a UFC champion and it goes back to
that thing like where Jocko says good
now obviously obviously childhood can
you just maybe halfway I'm not saying
that childhood trauma and abuse is good
I'm saying when you see the odds is what
you're saying and I think it gives
people who are going through a lot of
[__] that it gives them like he's an
example here's an example yeah I think
more that's why I said on the shop show
I think one of the reasons why he's so
beloved right now more people can relate
to Sean Strickland than they can of
LeBron James or Patrick Mahomes of
course because you know he's not he
doesn't run a 4 4 40. he comes from
horrible conditions he's not the fast
guy in the room he's not the most
powerful guy in the room he's not
shredded care does it not really but
people can relate to that and then also
which we talked about as well is in this
world of gimmicks and fake people and AI
he's as authentic as they get you might
not agree with all his opinions but at
least you know that's really him so
we're gravitating towards that so I
think that's why he's getting that's
another huge point is like I think that
Sean is
like just always tells the truth and you
know what I thought saw that when the
Stephen Bonner thing happened
he got on and he said you guys are all
you know talking now where were you when
he was trying to help him out and you
know when he he's not afraid to be
unpopular he just tells it like it is
you know um
you and I had this conversation with
Rogan about how he's got the biggest
podcast in the world and he probably has
the smallest team of anybody on the
planet like I think there are three
people that work for him well I mean but
as far as like compared to like what
runs the business actually the business
as far as the podcast it's Jamie there
you go Jamie's first ballot Hall of
Famer yeah and you go into his is that
you go into that studio it's the biggest
one of the biggest people in the world
are like the most you know the the
movers of the movers and shakers of the
world Elon it's like you me Elon Prince
Tripoli and you go in there you haven't
changed a lick you've the part of your
success is that you've stuck to what's
actually important what works and and I
and you just tell the truth because just
tell the truth just keep telling the
truth yep
so anyway
yeah so so any more thoughts on
Strickland Sonia what does arasania do
from here does he know what I don't I
don't want to see a immediate rematch I
don't I think as he needs some time I
think the fight October 21st which I
think we're competing for again the uh I
mean Boise Idaho well you'll miss it so
that's cool but the hamzat Apollo Costa
fight has more implications now that's a
bigger fight because those duplicities
as well but I think if hamzat starches
Apollo Costa he's gonna be next in line
but I think it's good for you to get a
rest let some other people go at it and
then come back I think it'd be a bigger
fight yeah I saw someone post the odds
have you uh Aaron uh Bruce Setter I
think it's onstetter bronze daughter he
said the current odds for Strickland as
champ dude
Izzy's a minus 400 again in the rematch
wow it's insane he and the only one he's
favored over is Canon air if they fight
next he's a underdog against duplicies
Underdog against homzat
well well I I think we'd all agree that
um arasania has greatness in him and
greatness means that no matter what he
finds a way to win like it was like
Muhammad Ali you could beat him the
first time you wouldn't beat him the
second time he'd come back and figure
something out and I think great Fighters
like uh Sonia it's it that's not a dumb
bet that's a smart bet just in general
if you look at it those odds are insane
that's insane that's basically saying
they're saying it's a fluke that's I
mean a minus 450. that's him gun it
wasn't happening it was not a fluke no
that that was my thing is and that's why
I'm a little against the rematch because
a I think is he needs rest no matter
what so if you do give him a rematch do
it midnight cheer that's fine but if
it's immediate rematch like in December
I don't like that or January I don't
like that but this wasn't like a uh Matt
Sarah GSP where he knocked him out right
away lucky right hand this is five
rounds of execution domination
his defense not getting just checking
those kicks and just not getting a mark
on his face that's yes we'll see what
the UFC does but again I think in the
world we live in now of this fake stuff
and clickbaity headlines that are you
click on the video on YouTube and some
you know you're like what happened you
click on that some you know crap I think
uh
um again I'll agree with everything he
says but Sean Strickland's a breath of
fresh air and I think if the UFC uses
that right he's gonna be a massive star
if you're if you're teaching if your
coaching comes out I'm not yeah are you
are you saying are you saying to him
just scrapple yeah just double leg blast
doubles no no I'm taking strike too no
yeah yeah that's the the hobside fights
tough
it is yes why uh Savage no I'm saying
I'm saying it's a fight for trickling
yeah because I'm not saying he can't win
and I don't agree with the odds but I'm
very high In Harm's lot haham's that's a
tough night in the office for Izzy at
his high level everything especially at
middleweight not cutting the weight he's
gonna be a problem the UFC I think wants
him to be the next Champion so it's
gonna be tough he's he's a tough one
well we're gonna he's coming we're gonna
see how he does against a big strong
opponent now if he if he mops for Palo
Costa trust me he's getting extile shot
yeah do police users out there probably
do Izzy do policies but not as a title
but yeah Paul Coster had you know so you
do you think that uh so you're saying
you don't think Izzy gets an automatic
rematch here now Dana said he does I'm
saying if I'm Izzy's Camp no okay no no
wait whether they want to give us two
polices and it's not for the title or if
they do want to give us rematch say you
need till April of next year why why
because he's been so active he's been as
heavy lies the ground he's been so
active you got to promote non-stop you
got a bull's eye on your back he pays
attention to social media heavy lies the
crown he's been so active man he's also
lost two F's last three right
he's lost three out of his last but what
is it uh out of seven fights he's lost
three it's a it's a little it gets tough
man it gets just
wear and tear the weight cutting the
camps I think coming off the ox pair
rematch took a lot out of him yeah he he
wasn't supposed to fight Strickland
remember this wasn't supposed to happen
they tried to look Beyond they're trying
to break yon versus Alex Pierre they
tried booking John and uh Sergey uh
pavlovich they tried a numerous
different fights and then finally they
had to go with Strickland and Izzy this
wasn't supposed to happen I mean
horrible horrible Mistake by Izzy in his
can
hmm
so I think it's a good time and also in
the business I'm in it's refreshing as
much as I love Izzy it's it's fun like
it's something new something to talk
about right that's great right gives me
energy I can't wait to come to studio
today
yeah man I mean it's it's really
exciting it's really exciting uh does
Sean I wonder do you think Sean spends a
lot of time dealing with wrestlers who
would shoot on him really good wrestlers
and stuff like that he sparse I'm sure
he surprised everybody he needs to not
change anything nothing do what got you
to the dance and he's not giving me a
guy that changes people getting his ear
and oh man let's focus just on wrestling
now no no you know you know you know the
game plan was for him to wrestle in that
fight even second round Nick sick was
like all right man it's Optics look for
the takedown lady in the round no he
he's like nope this is working for me
Sean's gonna Sean struggling in a strict
yeah
um good yeah
I I I I just was thinking like
how Bo nickel must be chomping the
[__] to get in there in general and
just just do his wrestling thing grab
guys and just you know yeah
he's gonna start now now that Izzy's out
there look you know it's gonna get
interesting with bow too because they
haven't announced his next fight right
chin bow Nichols see bringing them up
slow
he's the one just foaming you know he's
like foaming he's like if I grab a hold
of you
he doesn't want to come back that fast
willing to wait to 2024. what what
happened is he taking time off
just says not in a rush okay so what
yeah I'm with you it's a marathon not a
Sprint like just wait
he'll probably get a good name next or
big name
just wait no rush okay he has an injury
no oh no nothings he didn't get touched
last fight just taking some time
all right smart
Beast
August
smart dude man
it it really does it energize
the cards now I'm just so excited I'm so
excited for 185 to just see what happens
now looks like for a lot of things dude
I'll tell you what I found a nice little
comedian with my since I got that Dodge
that TRX there's a lot of Dodge fans out
there really I had a real Community
around me now you do oh man and these
boys we like the mod okay what is you
think we're gonna leave that stocks
notifications oh we like the mods
because that's a Hellcat engine that
thing Brandon hold on you know the
Limitless pill just do that but that's
for your car you not get crazy because
I'm looking at it it already looks all
tricky well look don't say tricky
tricked out
your car looks tricky it looks tricky
dude like what do you need to upgrade it
for like that engine has so much
potential but you're gonna keep the
tires because they're big yeah don't do
that yeah
is that that bumper stick that baja
bumper stick yeah it's sick but it's so
easy to get the thousand horsepower and
I found a a shop up this road in Semi
Valley but don't don't what are we doing
you're gonna go a thousand horsepower
how much the potential is there what
kind of horsepower does it have now 705
you don't need more than that you don't
need potentials there no we don't need
that though because that's that's all
you want to hear is the engine and you
see you have a weird thing you want to
know that it's there yeah you want to
know you got the horses in the stable in
case you got to let them out dude to put
a thousand horses under your hood but
you don't need one thousand horses but
but but but then you get a block a
gallon not not four miles a gallon oh no
you're not rational bro oh no you ain't
rational that's the cars I don't tow
anything
I know but I I don't I don't race
anything that's just nice to know is
this your number one driver now uh yeah
I mean when I get yeah because your kids
fit in it but you're a sports car guy
but then you like a giant too but yeah I
I've had a lot of cool cars it's gonna
be tough to beat that TRX really oh man
it's good your color the color's a
little tricky tan yeah sandblast yeah
you know what it is you know what the
thing is it's not for you I feel like
they did they make the the car that
Brian would never buy a Thai challenge
if you want a car that Brandon likes
make make a car that that Brian would
never buy yeah and then and then Tesla
with the model three that went very
aggressive what screams I suck [__]
what's what what car should we make
where people get out ass first why are
you making me a power bottom why why
because I drive an electric car are you
turning me into it what kind of car
could represent the gay parade in
Hollywood this week I don't get out of
my car Tesla three perfect don't get out
of my car
like me why are you
ask first every time boink I I gotta
drink my
little magic mine yeah I've already had
too much coffee so this is going to send
me over this is my third now I'm now
this is going to dilate all my holes
see that's that Tesla talk dude
oh me and my boys on the TRX forums
don't talk like that mental clarity
a lot of mental Clarity yeah that's
what'll happen
one coffee guy a day
I take these now that yeah I know I
always say that drink it with coffee see
what happens you know how much coffee is
to take I know that I it does something
it keeps the caffeine lasting longer or
something I don't know what it does try
it that's all I say yeah try a magic
mine with coffee and tell me what you
think try without coffee then try it
with coffee and honestly tell me how you
feel and I've been up since four yeah I
was I was chomping at the bit to jump on
those TRX forums chat with the boys
cars man we're talking trucks where are
you we're gonna meet up
we're gonna we're gonna meet up
we meet up you
[__] nerd I'm in I'm in you nerd
you're gonna go meet up somewhere in
Malibu you're gonna be like you're like
hey look like this no not you are you uh
are you big wheels one two three yeah
man I am oh man have you met exhaust 743
over there you met double exhausted
bumper dude are those 37s and then what
kind of course the exhaust I mean you're
gonna hear nothing you're just gonna
hear silence and you're gonna and you're
gonna go is that Brian getting out ass
first of his electric car no no no this
isn't even happened what's up good to
see you boys Dude Sweet RX I love the
new color
and then we go I'm gonna look at lexico
get out the [__] and then we open up the
bed truck and goes and Mike's going get
over here and then you have a ball in
your mouth fellas which is I think I
just brought this just my body I just
brought beers that's the least I can do
I'm new to the community
I share my friend and so I all you see
is me in the trunk and my ass is just
sticking out of the trunk yep
and I go load them up would it be weird
if you looked down and I had a huge
boner right now well you do yeah it's
kind of party we're doing you Gearheads
are so [__] thirsty do your words oh
yeah
I know I didn't get a chance to bleach
my taint sorry guys that's all good
little oil a little oil
uh I told you I've never been the same
since I saw that in Saudi Arabia right
when I was a kid yeah I know yeah that
messed me up I had his ass out of the
trunk of the car and another guy was
that again
disturb you man it's about 13. yeah
remember my friend Michael goes I'm so
glad I'm leaving me too man yeah that
was a tough one we saw it he looked at
us and we ran away that'll change it
forever yeah that wasn't changing
forever I was like because at first you
don't know what's going on first you
know you're not 13 you're like I was
like what am I see these guys wrestling
what is going on I'm seeing an ass out
of a there's a guy in the trunk of a car
with his ass hanging was he tied up or
he was no he wanted to do it he had his
whole body like this in the trunk of the
car like brace himself on the back seat
I guess and he had but he was in the
trunk and then his ass was sticking out
of it why why why not just do it another
guy was standing up and he was in and it
was in a junkyard it was in a Oh I
thought it was like in the side of the
road we were in an abandon lot looking
for snakes and scorpions oh would you
asked for you asked for boys too you
asked for and we see we look over and
there's a guy doing that looking for
snakes and scorpions and it falls deep
in his buddies but and I remember I
didn't know what was happening and I
remember we both looked over and then
he turned and saw us and did he just
keep going like I have kids
I think
did your buddy I think he turned and
looked at us with his dong in the air
wow yeah aggressive and then
they knew that that's something probably
to run from that's not something to run
towards you run from that your instinct
takes it yeah because they need fresh
meat yeah you get very you learn very
quickly as a young boy whether you're
straight or not your Spidey senses yeah
yeah your buddy went to it but even if
you're if you're gay that's that's a
threatening thing with a grown man and
you're a kid and you go oh that's not
something's wrong no you're looking for
scorpions not weiner yeah we didn't find
any scorpions that day
snakes I think we went home and we just
I remember we God drinks and we just sat
quietly yeah that'll change us I'm scary
what do you got chin
alrighty did you guys watch the fight by
the way yeah of course you guys both
watched it yeah
how fun was Covina together oh dude
first time for in a while fighting a kid
18 years we got up there and uh did uh a
live podcast basically not really I did
stand up we had a house I did you just
stand there came out to a q a yeah yeah
live podcast live podcasts are tough
when's the next time you guys are
together skank Fest yeah skank Fest
we're gonna do it we're doing a live
firing kid with the skank Fest crew
there and then I don't know if they have
us going on together hopefully they do
maybe they organize do you understand
how long are those sets like 10 minutes
45 minutes each no I'm just kidding it's
usually 10 15 minutes you imagine three
sets of 45 minutes in height like how
much are they paying us it's gonna be
fun though
the boys
Big Jay and Lewis yeah big Jay Lewis Dan
Soder Dave Smith who's my Messiah smart
guy loved it Dave I just regurgitate
whatever he says yeah
all right what do you got Jen all right
first one chin should come out you'd be
a fan favorite out there what is it what
is this month uh September 29th the big
Comedy Festival in Vegas
and they're doing like old school I
think it's like uh Fremont Street right
the old school Vegas oh that's sick I
remember yeah jelly roller performed I
think for one of them yeah at that place
yeah yeah
I'm coming to La I said sweet man he
goes wanna meet up let's let's do a
podcast I'm like sounds good he goes
cool man I'm super close I'm in
Bakersfield
I was like oh dude that's like two hours
away he's like what I'm like yeah he's
like I'm not gonna make it I'm like yeah
dude two hours there's no way
Bakersfield but we did book a very
special guest I don't like saying the
guest name until they come on because
then it's a letdown but yeah I'll tell
you after you'll be excited really
you'll be excited
let's wait for fire and kid yeah great
all right so this is more for Brendan so
I guess this psychologist kind of
figured out why people like to watch
True Crime stuff especially when they go
that's what kind of car does he drive
fishy can I guess what it is sure
they like to watch it because it arms
them with information and they can be
ready for something if it happens to you
nope we're close enough I'm not saying
no it's a very simple thing they say
that right here
it's because watching stressful Sinister
stuff like that is more relaxing to them
because they have some sort of inner
trauma that they don't want to deal with
oh wow yeah Brandon makes sense
unsolved trauma thank you and watch some
stress one Center shows more relaxing
than properly working through yep so
that would be like when you if you're a
hyperactive kid and they give you
Ritalin which was basically Adderall I
guess your body will compensate for it
and calm you down so it's like the same
thing yes so if you stress the body even
more the body will then yeah kick off if
I don't have something like uh True
Crime to watch like a documentary on
serial killers last night I watched this
documentary oh I forget the name of it
but I when I was saying I'm like Brian
could never want you would be talking
the whole time you'd hate it because if
you don't believe it it's gonna be the
worst thing but it's these two
paranormal uh people they've started
since they were like six years old and
they have a museum a traveling Museum
they're like one of the most famous
traveling paranormal museums and they
get sent stuff to them all the time and
he's like nine times out of ten or ten
times out of ten it's nothing we don't
see anything because then we got this uh
on Reddit they have a paranormal thread
on there this guy was like hey my buddy
found this thing in the woods
um it was on like this Ukrainian
property like a large Ukrainian property
he found it he did the thing you're
never supposed to do is take touch and
take it home takes it home this guy
doesn't believe in ghosts in any facet
so this is why it scared me because this
guy's like you he's like [__] takes
it home all this stuff starts to happen
to him he's like what do we do please
help us the guy's like yes send to us
we'll check it out he's thinking him his
wife likes me some [__] they get it
and they have it sitting there and and
the strange stuff starts happening to
them and he's like what the hell's going
on here so they set up cameras in the in
the left and their offset of cameras and
it shows the thing move and he's like
what like then this other stuff starts
to happen
long story short they found out that
it's this and their whole the whole kind
of agenda of the documentary everyone
has you know the uh an agenda was that
just because it's haunted it doesn't
mean it's evil like this thing was in
the middle
like it was some sort of Ukrainian or uh
I forget what kind of God it was but it
was like stuck in there and they had to
release it wow it was two hours and
which makes it an hour and 45 minutes
too long but um the 15 minutes you could
wrap that in 15 minutes but it was
that's worth a watch that's most books
most books you read you're like oh this
could have been they gave it away in the
first 15 minutes and I was like okay and
then you know that with most books like
the argument that you the the thing you
need from the intro 25 Pages the forward
and then what happens is your publisher
goes you can't release a 20 Page book
and charge 25 for 29 dollars you got a
300 example so you make it longer so
then you get a 300 400 page book but
yeah it's interesting but the point is
is I didn't have anything dark to watch
last night so I randomly searched apple
found that documentary and then I fell
asleep to Ghost Adventures sometimes I
fall asleep I've dude I've fall asleep
to the Jeffrey Dahmer doc I don't know
40 times
well you definitely seem like you have
some sort of a inner issues you haven't
worked out yet that's interesting yeah
especially
where's the list start
this doctor doesn't have a TRX that's
all right hey Brendan's starting to talk
about some of that stuff on stage yeah
working out some uh yeah stuff in the
standing some dark bits it's good though
yep let it out
uh so Kim Jong-un is apparently on a
train right now which is like a
incredibly heavy train that's
bulletproof it only goes 37 miles per
hour it's so heavy yeah heading to meet
up with Putin apparently and talk about
an arms deal that's what I'm hearing
interesting hmm
damn that thing looks sick the TRX of
trains so it says it covers 683 miles in
about 20 20 hours oh it's so slow yeah
and then here's some pictures of it
inside oh I bet the inside's lit dude
or is it right there's the president of
China
no I'm saying I bet the interior like
this because he knows it only goes
they're like hey man it was 37 miles an
hour he's like okay cool I need a
PlayStation 5 on there I need 80 inch
screen TVs and you get my little wiener
so you know that's pretty bad though you
know because Kim jong-un's haircut
Schult Andrew Schultz that's not
original
Kim Jong-un didn't know it for and his
daddy had it before him
that's a yeah that's a wild haircut yeah
that's cool keeps it tight around the
ears high and tight Kim Jong-un is not
winning any beauty contest I don't think
he cares no no he's the king he's a king
that's his sister there that's his
assistant I don't know
that I don't know I think this is his
wife though that's so crazy that is his
wife that's his father on the train way
back
oh so it's the same train the update
that does red leather now
yeah there's a pink well it looks like
pink right I bet you that Train's pretty
cool
you guys ever been on like a legit train
they're sweet they're nice yeah
especially in Europe way cooler I don't
see anything windows I don't know this
train looks terrible that lighting looks
I mean it's bulletproof so you got to
have you know yeah
bulletproof he's just trying to get
there slow as a snail yeah
uh it looks terrible I just saw this pop
up that Jerry Seinfeld has a 100 million
dollar car collection and because of his
royalties from Seinfeld which ended in
the 90s he still gets 60 to 80 million a
year and then you know Spike his boy
Spike who they started uh Malibu the
coffee Club
which is gone now I think they're
bringing it back with his boy Spike
who's a writer on Seinfeld he's like
super car guy so Jerry Seinfeld like you
know Jay Leno knows cards and stuff like
that but Seinfeld definitely knows cars
but him and his boy Spike and they have
another guy they have a bunker I think
it's in uh Baldwin Hills and they have
all their cars there but they're like
this get due to drive for this month the
other guy drive for that month and like
share all these crazy crazy cars nice
it'd be so dope man it'd be so dope
first and is that him
yeah it's Mike
oh I was in a car yeah he's a big pod
but yeah he's Super Car Guy and they're
and Jerry Seinfeld is uh Porsche like
super Porsche man oh Porsche all day
cars
yeah
that's at the Malibu uh farm right there
sweet
uh maybe not because he has a scarf on
you wouldn't wear a scarf in Malibu I
mean in Winter no no I think I know
exactly where that is actually yeah it
looks like it but
I think that's off of Cross Creek that's
in that that area and that's I don't
think Starbucks is right next door this
credit is from
fameflinet.uk yeah I don't know you
you'd be an [__] to dress like that
Malibu but then also there's no yoga
studio on that strip no yoga smoke
because I take my kiddos there got it
no that's not it no it is that's the
yoga smoker Malibu yeah oh yeah Malibu I
was right
yeah oh they're just dressed like
[__] now you can see it's cold it's
not certain times a year a scarf yeah
you know how cold it has been open when
you're driving it goes well with your
pores in the sun yeah you know how cold
it has to get for me to wear a skull
it's been cold in Malibu at times when
that wind blows you can be no 40. that's
all spoiled 35 degrees out no way dude
I've been in here
all right we got you
all right you said what Georgie I said I
haven't wore a scarf since I was like
five oh tough move it's tough you gotta
starfish giving off some weird vibe
unless mommy wraps it around you then
the only guy I've seen pull off a scarf
well is Frank Grillo oh me too he wore
one here yeah he can pull in the summer
yeah he's just the scarf what about
Couture right a Couture oh yeah Randy
wears a scarf too
he could pull off a dress if you're that
much and you look that good oh Freddy
Walker that dress in here I wouldn't
even allude to it yeah like so which
what have you been up to yeah look at
him he looks awesome yeah scarves do
look sweet yeah I mean he's a stud well
when uh Handsome when La became North
Korea we had to wear masks all the time
man I used to wear the the bandana I
used to turn around I look cute oh cute
yeah okay I'd wear the scarf the bandana
like I felt like a Hell's Angel a little
bit I just turned it around to the
little ears would stick out it's tie-dye
there you go cute man oh my God that
you're wearing your bike yeah you never
got into motorcycles too dangers yeah
if I didn't have kids I'd probably drive
one right now really oh yeah
I'm like Vince Diesel now dude I live my
life
it's his brother oh no oh you thought
someone oh he's wrong brother Vincent
Diesel that's his full name Vincent
Diesel says I live my life one quarter
mileage I've seen you go Vince and he's
like Brandon I hate when you do that
you're like what are you in when you go
we're gonna do about a tough guy and he
goes yeah no no not messing around with
you yeah yeah you're calling Vince yeah
so Vince for Vincent Diesel that is his
real name though yeah Mark Vincent yeah
come by his first name dude no I knew
that
this is a Justin gaichi he had to wear a
dress hanging out with his friends
because of fantasy football
I see football last year
he is not an attractive woman
he's all Dead series oh yeah it's
fantasy football I bet it's comfortable
that looks refreshing a dress yeah start
wearing one
uh I'm a little too angular but he he
looks thin enough though he punches
people in the face yeah it might look a
little too good on me and he looks
that's your problem yeah he looks all
trapped out there he's good that win
picks up shows that Apple Bottom yeah oh
on a Malibu summer day
we're going to be looking at some cold
iced tea a little lemonade oh stop it
what else all right
um Nina Agdal who's obviously Logan
Paul's fiance I guess she got a
restraining order against Dylan danis
from posting some like really explicit
yeah images of her from way back I guess
from like 10 years ago but she actually
got a restraining order it went through
yeah that could get dicey for him man
yeah it's just not cool
yeah I think there's other ways to
promote it but he did his job if you
wanted attention and that's why he
signed a fight Dylan danis he did his
job so I didn't say how he was going to
do it Logan but he's doing his job yeah
but is he gonna fight Logan yeah he's
gonna fight hopefully so so
um they did a Face-Off was he born that
one posting x-rated photos of her I
don't know he said he was [__] shaming
then they had a video going around it
turns out the woman in the picture is
not her apparently I guess or could be
doctored I don't know
a picture
but when you think about KSI and Tommy
Fury nobody's talking about that the
only reason anybody's talking about this
fight is Dylan Dennis say what you want
about him I don't agree with what he did
but if you wanted views don't bring the
view how is ksi's boxing Better Than
Jake Paul's as good no okay not even
close so he's gonna fight Tommy Fury
though that's a terrible fight for KSA
yeah terrible I heard Dylan's like his
social media like he was he was gaining
like 600 000 in a day when he was doing
that post and then like like Millions
dude he posted a video today I saw nine
million views it's insane yeah on
Twitter so I mean that's the biggest
promotion you could possibly do then
again it sucks but you wanted guys to
bring click to it okay how are you gonna
do it don't worry about it yeah Tim
that's yeah I guess if you're both
playing that game again you play that
game man these kids these younger kids
there's no nothing's off rules because
we'll we'll watch Yeah well yeah but but
younger people will yeah oh yeah
all right so your boy Dion Sanders his
bodyguard I guess he went viral first
t-shirt I love it
security guards I said you guys need the
shirt that Dion's security has says [__]
around find out and there's a little
image of a person like having you know
[__] the A on their own t-shirt not
great
oh really Gallagher
who got all all crazy busted and then
they they were able to break him out
like that's his saying fafo find around
[__] out you know
oh wow yeah he basically he beat the
Navy
because you know he was this guy who got
busted in uh Iraq and but it was
fraudulent charges and [__] is this
stuff
Eddie Gallagher Eddie Gallagher was
initially arrested on quote-unquote war
crimes right and his some of his
teammates when we were at War yes made
these made made some stories uh oh I
remember the whole time stories about
him shooting uh at one point an old man
a young girl and then when they were put
on the stand
the entire testimony fell apart because
nobody had actually seen anything
apparently he was a badass leader yes
right and he kicked butt when he had to
yeah and he was uh and I listened to the
interview that Andy stump did with him
Andy stump being a fellow seal it's very
interesting because if you actually hear
it and you hear what the gov what the
government came to with their their
evidence it all fell apart and all of it
nothing stood and so he was but he was
kept in jail for about nine months and
for the most part not allowed to speak
to anybody that's terrible well it's
what they do but at the end of the day
you know he was exonerated fully and
completely good
so we'll [__] around find out man yeah
but he was a he was uh I I actually knew
one of the guys in his team and uh he
would say about Eddie said look I I
never saw anything like that he was a
hell of a seal but he was also the kind
of guy that they'd be out there and and
to be like we got to be up in four hours
and Eddie would go and work out he's
like I don't know how the [__] he does
yeah and Brian it's [__] War bro yeah
man you want monsters you don't want
[__] yeah and then people get mad
when these guys you know do this [__]
yeah Lex where you were in uh you're in
Somalia yeah I'm going to Iraq though
early next year are you yeah are getting
the troops MMA gnarly
by the way I'll just be doing work from
Iraq on a cell phone yeah by the way I
got you yeah Lex is always available oh
yeah uh that's what else you got this
was the dumbest [__] I've ever seen play
this okay so it is kind of anti what not
to do with a bear what not to do with a
bear
dum dum over here showing off for his
friends come on Mike come on
oh you don't dress like that not a dog
bro that's the starter kit for dumbass
look at how close he is look how close
he is to that bear
so dumb
give that bear give that bear some
[__] this guy thinks he's like a dog
yeah treating it like it this is exactly
how you get [__] up what hey hey
Mike's about to die that bear could just
make one decision and you're [__] that
Bear's trying to decide like
this guy's [__] around he needs to
find out and get your hand
s
did he tear him up bad cut him not
terrible scratched him up the Blood
starts to seep out I was so lucky that
was so dumb you know what that guy's a
hero for 30 seconds
that's not bad I know he could have died
pretty bad
get leave the bear alone give the bear
room now let him do his thing man
like that guy shouldn't be allowed to
vote
I agree with you leave the government
should look at that video nah man no you
don't give us a lot more pressure yes
and Georgie uh this is a social media
influencer named Charleston white he uh
he's known for Just Cause wild boy yeah
Wild Boy and he's gonna do a boxing
match he also has one eye they're doing
the face off here and just pepper sprays
do in the face the funniest is the ring
card girl's like oh my God watch watch
this boom look at the ring car girls did
you know how it hit it goes everywhere
look what starts getting there like uh
no
that's really weird
yeah
white pepper sprayed his eyes you ever
been pepper sprayed yes oh it's bad
yes I I [__] helped a woman who got
pepper spray oh that's right and then it
got in my eyes you know how I got pepper
sprayed we're at my grandpa's house I
was like five or six years old I was at
my grandpa's house and my dad was going
through a stuff in his garage when he
passed away but I was like oh look
pepper spray he's like I don't think it
worked am I shaking it and there's a
wind but I was behind like what is
happening right now my dad's like see if
it works and the wind went cool stories
when she was nine I went like this I
looked at my dad went good
remember that conversation earlier about
who hurt you Brendan yeah now we're
starting to get a clear picture yeah
Peter schaab yeah hurting you big time
pepper spray in the eyes when I was uh
when my daughter was I think probably
six or seven actually she found the
pepper spray I get to my my wife at the
time I had her cute and she [__]
sprayed it in her face she's not allowed
to vote it was very bad about she's on
six doesn't matter no no voting rights
life yeah this bad situation yeah we had
a runner I was raised no punk dude
aren't you supposed to put milk in your
eyes better than mace
uh Dove Davidoff had this guy came out
his window tried to pull him out of a
car and Dove was like I'm from New York
just dressed him down
yeah it really dude there's not much the
toughest guys in the world unless
they're ready for there's not much you
can do UFC somebody gets I poke first
thing they was like what the [__] yeah
yeah I mean you mess with the eyes I
don't care how muscular you are your
eyes you can't put muscle around your
eyes but you're a girl gonna be like
you're so brave if you're like what do
you want to do
oh man I told you that guy was amazing
he just yeah this guy was they were
using the n-word and he was this tall
handsome black guy and the guy what the
[__] did you say he comes in his face
just like that and without like so lazy
he just went and the girl was you mother
[__] and she was the one who dropped
the network she comes in his face he
goes and I get there and he looks at her
and goes put milk in your eyes it'll
help you and get some scrago what
happened he goes just people clowning
[__] idiots because I know all the
cops here and they're gonna be fine it's
not like you ruined your eyesight that
one dude who did it soap it up right
quick climb what crawled over into a
doorway into a like a foyer of a doorway
and I was like
I was trying to help the girl I go give
me some water I'm grabbing water and
then it just got in my eyes I was
[__] it's the worst what's the worst
thing that had happened if you had
pepper sprayed like that or mace you
can't lose your eyesight right like it
goes away it's gonna suck it's gonna
suck for a few days but it goes you can
get it can can you lose uh vision I
think if you're super drunk and you
don't
watch it out like if it stays in
probably
a journal investigative uh uh OC is not
harmful
and there's no evidence saying pepper
spray causes long-term vision problems
expression can trigger changes in
corneal sensitivity sure if you're
constantly getting sprayed who's like oh
man the tenth time this year that air
can hurt your eyes then yeah who gets it
more than once a lifetime now today's
mace is a different thing that's a
chemical it's face different uh yeah
mace is what the police use for major
riots uh well that's tear gas but mace
is a [__]
foreign
it still goes to pepper spray though are
you sure they're different see if mace
is uh
type in the difference between Mace and
pepper spray
there it is oh
traditional chemical and mace is
classified as a yeah traditional
chemical mace is classified tear gas
specialist classified as an inflammatory
agent
it sounds similar they both suck
it was found to be very toxic yeah the
original mace formula they both suck
yeah
what else you got Jen
alrighty oh it's pepper spray works it's
more effective on people under the
influence interesting
because sometimes tasers don't work on
big people oh yeah or if they're all
jacked up on Mountain Dew yeah that's by
Mountain Dew I mean math yeah that's it
doesn't work on PCP they have there is
there is actual videotaped evidence of
people getting shot multiple times in
close range like a zombie when they're
on uh PCP yeah and just being like ah
[__] just coming at you now you want
to get a head shot and that'll put them
out right you know you need Bass
you're right if you can't see right
there that's where you want to get you
you know those hand ones the taser guns
like this yeah those we tried on each
other me and my friends hell yeah some
people were like but me they just kept
going nothing I have a friend who used
to well I had friends who used to you
know they'd cup check and stuff and then
they got a hold of one of those things
and they would come up to people and go
damn that's not cool not people but I
mean each other yeah oh Jesus great it's
a good time
Ah that's fine I was are your friends
Hell's Angels pretty close this is just
a video
of an orca
oh man oh with a big dick giant dick
what a dick wow
and it's on Nature's metal wow boner
Central don't they have the biggest
wieners on the planet
no I'm telling you that I'm pretty sure
killer whales or orcas have the biggest
winners on the planet hard to argue with
yeah they have a bigger one you've seen
I'm gonna say blue whale but
no I don't think so man I think killer
whales there you go bro yeah
of course Brian would know I was right
well hold on in a red blue whale penis
is 12 inches long diameter oh 10 feet
high whoa 12 inches around whoa whoa
that is a unit that's a unit
that's a oh my God it's a big old man
that thing must be fun
I bet we've never seen one of those oh
there it is and then I'll be oh that
thing's floppy
that's a huge dong do you think that's
how people thought like Monsters were
real back in the day they'd see a big
whale weiner pop out well they're
probably like look at this whale has a
antenna it has a tentacle you know yeah
boy that is
hell yeah dude stuffed whale penis first
dude we should get for the studio Rogan
should get that for his he has all those
cool artifacts six G's though that's an
expensive wheelie big whale dick
you know how sick that would be on just
over the tfat case there's anything to
buy for Rogan that would be it yeah get
him a stuffed whale dick yeah that's one
thing he doesn't have it's the one thing
but the problem with that is if we put
above the sign people like when you have
that big
carrot was that the biggest care in the
world and you framed it no no no no
that's a whale yeah that's an ocean car
that's an ocean [__] that's that's a
water [__] call that a water water [__]
yeah called aqua dick Aqua dick Aqua
dick
the Biden Administration oh God
according to the according to the an
apple Court in uh New Orleans said that
uh you guys
were suppressing Free Speech when it
came to covet and people were being
censored you weren't forcing companies
like Facebook to take down on YouTube
take down yes take down any information
that even hinted at the origins of coven
light the lab League Theory and at hard
actual actionable science like badachary
and uh um
well what happens with that is now
you're open to a lawsuit and now
hopefully future future administrations
have to delineate between what's actual
criminal activity and Americans
expressing their opinions is YouTube
gonna take notes because it come for
them now when when it's a when it is a
federal court when it's brought to
appeal on a federal level yes you better
listen I hope you're going to be in some
trouble I would really help everybody
out yep so especially Comics man that's
today
well good man yeah is that itching
that's it all right I am in Spokane
Washington baby that is September 21st
through the 23rd I can't wait with my
faves Spokane comedy club and then skank
fest with my friend here we're doing a
live firing kid with a skank Fest crew
on the 29th that's Friday eight I think
and then me and Kyle will be doing spots
all over uh them in Iowa October 13th
through the 14th go Hawkeyes Niagara
Falls that's a casino November 4th
through the 5th Chicago's December 8th
and 9th get your tickets at thick
boy.com but Spokane Europe first
September 21st 23rd Daddy's at the
Omaha this weekend September 15 and 16
and then I'll be at the Comedy Zone
Greensboro North Carolina October 6th
and 7th let's go
hi kids love you